how's it going everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and
everything relating to the marvel
cinematic universe one division has been
absolutely fantastic it's been hilarious
and it also gets very dark and very
serious at some points but the best
thing about it which some people may
hate is that it leaves us wanting
questions it leaves us
asking what is happening now of course
we're going to get answers but
everything that has happened so far is
leading up to something
very very huge and we think we might
have figured out what it could be
based off of something that elizabeth
olsen who of course plays wanda
recently said in an interview if you
take what she said in this interview and
you combine it with
what paul bettany said in a different
interview then we can kind of start to
figure out what exactly is going on
and as i mentioned i think we might have
figured it out so
let's dive into it but first if you're
new be sure to subscribe so you don't
miss out on any of the latest
mcu videos so we all know that one
division is going to go
into doctor strange and the multiverse
of madness but kevin feige the president
of marvel studios also recently revealed
that it's going to also connect to
spider-man 3 which of course has doctor
strange in it who will most likely show
up in one division so keep that in mind
as we go forward in this video
now as i mentioned elizabeth olsen was
doing an interview with tv line
and in this interview she was asked if
there is going to be a shocking cameo
in one division similar to the
appearance of mark hamill's luke
skywalker
at the end of the mandalorian season 2.
and elizabeth olsen simply
responded with yes as the interview
continued she said that she was real
excited for fans to see
what the show had in store for them and
that we're in for some pretty big
surprises
over the next five weeks and then show
runner jack shaffer added
there are so many surprises left in
store i encourage
all fans to settle in because there's
more coming so this
is huge there's going to be a cameo
in one division that's going to be as
big as mark hamill's cameo as luke
skywalker
in the mandalorian just let that sink in
for a second
luke skywalker arguably the biggest if
not him
than darth vader but one of the biggest
star wars characters
ever and one of the original star wars
characters
from the original star wars films made a
cameo in the mandalorian
it was epic it was absolutely insane and
they're saying that we're going to get
something
equivalent of that in one division so
who exactly could that be well paul
bettany recently said in an interview
that he's going to work with an actor
that he's always wanted to work with
and this may give us a little bit more
of a hint as to who exactly is going to
be appearing
i think they're going to be massively
surprised by the
end of the show i mean just
i i think i really think people are
going to be like oh my god they're going
to
look at the mcu in a whole new light and
also
have a much deeper understanding about
in what direction it's moving um i would
also say that
you know so many things get leaked and
and people find out about certain things
can i just give them a little a little
taste
i wouldn't say too much but there's this
thing that's been kept completely under
wraps
that is that happens and i work with
this actor that i have
always wanted to work with oh and
we have fireworks together and
the scenes are great and
i think people will be really excited uh
i've always wanted to work
uh with this guy and
uh it's pretty the scenes are pretty
intense
now let's talk about that first thing
that paul bettany said in this interview
he said that he thinks that fans are
going to be massively surprised
by the end of the show and he really
thinks that people are going to be like
oh my gosh so this backs up the insanely
huge
luke skywalker type of cameo in one
division
this isn't just some person we've
already seen in the mcu showing up it's
insanely big
but he also said that we're going to
look at the mcu in a new light
but also have a much deeper
understanding
of what direction it's moving so as i
probably put somewhere in the title
i believe that this could be a cameo
from tobey maguire i think that we could
see toby maguire's peter parker appear
in the wand division series remember
what i said in the beginning of the
video
kevin feige confirmed that one division
will tie directly
into spider-man 3. well we've had a ton
of reports up until this point stating
that toby maguire is going to be
reprising his role as peter parker
spider-man and spider-man 3. furthermore
it's been reported that he could also
appear in doctor strange in the
multiverse of madness which again
juan division is going to directly lead
up to
now a cameo from tobey maguire is sort
of on par with a cameo from mark hamill
as luke skywalker because if you think
about it
he's from the beginning he's kind of an
original superhero as far as superhero
movies are concerned
at least with marvel spider-man came out
in 2001 and really the only
huge superhero movie from marvel that
came out before that was the x-men in
2000
which i will actually talk about in just
a second but toby is an
og he's the og spider-man at least as
far as movies are concerned because
there were live-action spider-man before
him just not in the movies and not
nearly as
big as his but this would be the cameo
that would make us all
completely lose our minds we would go
insane and this actually does tie even
more into what paul bettany was saying
he said that we're going to have a much
deeper understanding of what direction
it's moving
well we already know what direction one
division is moving
it's moving towards the multiverse it's
moving towards the multiverse of
madness so we know that at one point or
another the multiverse is going to
essentially
explode and chaos is going to happen and
a lot of different multiverses are
probably going to collide based off of
the title of doctor strange 2
multiverse of madness and since one
division connects directly into
multiverse of madness the multiverse
will probably burst into madness during
one division
which means we can get a cameo from
tobey maguire spider-man from the same
raimi universe
this could be how he appears in
spider-man 3. this could actually be
completely how spider-man 3 is set up
and also
side note awesome little fun fact here
we found out that one division actually
takes place before
spider-man far from home so technically
the multiverse is going to burst open
before the events of spider-man far from
home take place
and this actually explains a key detail
about spider-man far from home
mysterio lied and said that he was from
another
universe it's now clear that he made up
this lie and
shield believed him because the
multiverse was indeed
a very big part of what was happening
during that time
during the events of spider-man far from
home just a little thing that i noticed
there
but if all the rumors about toby maguire
and andrew garfield appearing in
spider-man 3
are true then a cameo as big as mark
hamill
appearing as luke skywalker in the
mandalorian could be
toby maguire spider-man appearing in one
division
now to play devil's advocate to my own
theory or mephisto's advocate
since i'm so bent on him appearing i
will say that there are two
other insanely huge options that i think
could happen as well
and that could be a cameo from patrick
stewart as professor xavier in one
division or
ian mckellen as magneto in one division
now i'm sure
some of you remember that it was
revealed by patrick stewart himself that
he recently met with kevin feige at
marvel studios where he discussed with
kevin feige
plans for professor xavier now
ultimately patrick stewart ended up
saying
that if he hadn't had said goodbye to
professor xavier
and logan he might be up for reprising
the role but unfortunately
he said goodbye to professor xavier but
he said goodbye to professor xavier and
he said no to returning
as a full-time character the great thing
about the multiverse is
is that it can be a different version of
professor xavier
one that had a different fate than the
one in logan and as i've stated before
if he appears simply as an alternate
version
of professor xavier this would probably
only be for a quick cameo which wouldn't
really require any commitment to marvel
studios
just one film that would only take
probably only a day or two of filming it
would make the fans go
absolutely crazy to see him in the mcu
and it wouldn't offset the death in
logan and patrick stewart is one of the
og superheroes from marvel as well
the original x-men film debuted in 2000
and along with patrick stewart as
professor xavier was ian mckellen
debuting as magneto now for those of you
who are big comic fans you know that at
one point in time
in the comics it was said that magneto
was actually the father
of awanda and petro and for a very very
long time
this is what marvel comics went with so
a possible cameo from ian mckellen as
magneto would definitely be
a mark hamill luke skywalker level cameo
and would certainly fit within the one
division story relatively well
now just a little bonus thought here i
would love to say there's a possibility
of hugh jackman's wolverine appearing
which of course there is a possibility
but i don't think that's the route that
marvel's going to go down but still
it's possible paul bettany has said that
he's wanted to work with this actor
for a very long time and that they
clicked together and they worked really
well together do you think that this is
toby maguire
patrick stewart or ian mckellen or
somebody else let me know your thoughts
in the comments down below i'm
personally hoping for
any one of these three but i think we
would all absolutely freak out if toby
mcguire's spider-man showed up in one
division but let me know how you feel in
the comments down below don't forget to
like the video and subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest mcu
news for live updates you can follow me
on instagram and twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching
woof